an weihnachten in einer notunterkunft zb
kein geld um den kindern etwas zu
schenken das ist realität mitten in
deutschland und zwar dort wo im sommer
die jahrhundertflut zuschlug wo
insgesamt 180 menschen ums leben kam
trotzdem oder gerade deshalb an
weihnachten ohne geschenke darf nicht
sein sagen sich drei engagierte frauen
und wurden mit hilfe vieler spender zu
den weihnachtsengeln formate
im juni kam das wasser überflutete das
aartal mit verheerenden folgen mehr als
130 menschen verloren ihr leben hunderte
häuser wurden verwüstet nur notdürftig
sind die schäden beseitigt viele
menschen stehen vor dem nichts wie
können menschen wie können familien
weihnachten feiern wenn es am nötigsten
fehlt an geld für die bescherung sowieso
diese frage stellten sich auch mandy
simone und alina und so wurden die drei
frauen zu den weihnachtsengeln vom areal
das ziel den menschen im flutgebiet eine
schöne bescherung machen und langsam die
geschichte von diesen wunschbaum damit
wir direkt familien mehr oder weniger
unterstützen können hinten mal hören was
brauchen sie noch was fehlt ihnen das
die familien als auch zum größten teil
die wo wir sonst gar keine möglichkeit
haben dran zu kommen denn viele von der
flut betroffene schämen sich ihre
bedürftigkeit offen zu zeigen so konnten
die kinder bei einem weihnachtsfest ihre
wünsche auf eine karte schreiben und an
den baum hängen ja also das waren die
wunschzettel die lagen dann halt hier
und wenn die familien kamen mit den
kindern dann haben wir halt hier hinten
durften die kinder dann ihren wunsch
eintragen und hier der name adresse
telefonnummer damit wir dann auch in
kontakt sein können mit den familien
rund 80 geschenkwünsche sammelten simone
mandy und alina so ein mit hilfe einer
facebook seite wurden bundesweit paten
gewonnen die die geschenke besorgten
ohne jugend eine preisliche obergrenze
doch die meisten wünsche der kinder sind
bescheiden der skurrilste eigentlich ich
wünsche mir nebel für die rand also das
war dann schon ziemlich wohl überlegt
nägel für die wand aufhängen wir basteln
denn viele haben in der flut alles
verloren so wie die familie zum b aus
bad breisig ihre wohnung wurde völlig
zerstört seitdem leben die zombies in
einer notunterkunft nur mit dem
nötigsten ausgestattet
umso größer die freude über die
geschenke darunter eine spielekonsole
und ein elektroauto für francisco finow
den jüngsten
wir sind es erst licht erstmalig
55 ich weiß nicht was ich sagen kann
noch bis kurz vor heiligabend geht die
verteilung der geschenke weiter und
danach ist noch lange nicht schluss wir
werden also patenschaften jetzt
sozusagen aufgebaut wo die
unterstützer den familien helfen mit
dingen die sie dann noch brauchen also
sozusagen war ein eigentlich die
wunscherfüller
wunschbaumaktion ein türöffner und
zugleich ein kleines aber wichtiges
stück weihnachtsglück im aartal
[Musik]
und wir sind jetzt mit unserem kollegen
jonathan under verbunden der den film
gibt gestern gedreht hat und jetzt auch
weiterhin vor ort ist immer teil
jonathan wie ist denn die geschenke
verteilung gelaufen haben denn schon
alle geschenke dann auch die wunsch
stelle erreicht
ja bis jetzt haben viele der geschenke
die gewünschten orte erreicht viele
eltern viele kinder sind beschenkt
worden aber ich will gar nicht lange
drum herum reden denn zwei der
weihnachtsengel stehen jetzt neben ja
simone und alina und die können wir das
eigentlich am besten uns erklären simone
wie waren die reaktionen der eltern und
besonders der kinder als jeder gestern
und auch heute noch unterwegs sei also
die reaktionen sind sehr unterschiedlich
zwischen weinen lachen glücklich sein
die kinder haben tränen in den augen
weil die könnte eigentlich gar nicht
fassen also sind schon die wunderschöne
reaktion als es wirklich auch
herzenswünsche waren man jetzt nicht
einfach nur ich packe meinen koffer
sondern wirklich herzenswünschen
die geschenke sind ja auch durch spenden
durch patenschaften entstanden wer sind
denn die paten dahinter wer ist das das
ist ganz unterschiedlich bekommen
teilweise aus ganz deutschland kommen
aus berlin die kommen aus dem saarland
die kommen aus bayern also wie ich
konnte geschenke täglich überall
verteilen und dementsprechend konnten
auch alle herzenswünsche erfüllt werden
also das ist ganz ganz wichtig es waren
herzenswünschen simone sind ja noch
weitere aktionen noch weitere aktien
geschenk aktionen geplant wie sieht das
aus was ist da genau geplant kannst du
uns da ein wein ja ich kann euch ein
weiter so wir versuchen jetzt bei ist
noch ganz ganz viele geschenke da und
wir wollen die kinder jetzt nicht so
massiv geholfen das wäre dann die
nächste flut die sie erleben da haben
wir überlegt dass wir uns eventuell mit
mehreren leuten irgendwie kugeln auf
einer karnevalsveranstaltung machen
sofern das die kohle ohne regeln
zulassen dass die kinder sich verkleiden
dürften und dann dürfen sie also nochmal
geschenken
klasse vielen dank simone tolle aktionen
wir wünschen dir ganz viel erfolg
weiterhin bei bild und dankeschön und
auch wir sagen danke